what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where i help you break into data science
and grow your skills in the field this
is another video in my r tutorial series
and specifically it's the third and
final video in my series covering the
tidy models suite of packages for
machine learning
so if you haven't seen the first two
videos they will be in the description
of this video
highly obviously recommend watching
those two before getting into this one
but where we left off in the last video
was
we had just gone through workflows
so a workflow is just a container which
puts all the pieces of the machine
learning pipeline into one condensed
object
so we had done in the last tutorial
a random forest where we specified to
the m try hyper parameter that we're
going to tune that
later that's why we pass this tune
function to f2
uh to the m tri hyper parameter argument
here
but then even things like the recipe
which contains things like
the pre-processing steps and down
sampling of the training
set that goes into the workflow as well
as this model
and then at workflow we're going to fit
that to our training set
we did that then we evaluated the
performance on the testing set
we found that there was overall a hit to
accuracy here
when we introduced down sampling but our
sensitivity and specificity are a little
bit more balanced
like i just pointed out though we
specified for this m tri
hyper parameter that we're going to tune
it later using this tune function here
and that's where this tune packaging
tidy models is going to come in
that's the first thing that we're going
to cover in this tutorial
so if all that sounds good to you smash
the like button to this video and keep
watching until the end
also subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already and hit the notification
bell so youtube notifies you whenever i
upload a video
then lastly if you guys would be willing
to support me above and beyond that
i do have links in the description of
this video to things like my patreon
account paypal account
and my crypto wallet addresses your
support is highly appreciated
and then of course this script will be
available on my github repo
you can also find that in the
description of the video
now without further ado let's get
started
so if you've seen my carrot tutorial
series or if you're just generally
familiar with the carrot package then
you know all about the train control
function
out of carrot so what i would commonly
do in the tutorial series was
i would want to do a five-fold repeated
cross-validation resampling approach
but then i would also define what's
known as a tuning grid
so a tuning grid is nothing more than a
manually specified
range of values that i would want to
search for
for my hyper parameter with the goal of
optimizing some metric
like area under the receiver operating
characteristic curve
well we're going to do those exact same
steps using the tidy models
a framework here now when we do
five-fold cross-validation
that means that we're essentially
splitting our data into five
roughly equally sized groups now those
equally sized groups are known as the
folds
so when you hear me refer to folds well
that's what we're talking about
now that entire process is repeated
multiple times that's where the
uh repeats equals five comes from
but the first thing that we're going to
do is we're going to
store those folds in their own object
now to do this we're going to use this
v-fold cv
function which comes from the r sample
package that's actually the very
first uh packaging tidy models that we
worked with at the beginning of this
tutorial series
but the configuration for however you
want to do your resampling is going to
come in
is going to come in here so v equals
five
repeats equals five we're going to store
that in this folds object
okay moving on to the next step we're
going to specify the tuning grid
we're going to do this by using the
expand.grid function
and we're going to specify we want to
search over a range of and try could be
3 to 15.
now we're ready to rock and roll from
that workflow that we created earlier
we're going to pipe to it the tune grid
function
to the resamples argument we're going to
pass the folds that we just defined
to the grid argument we're going to pass
this rf grid object we just defined
that just contains the values of mtri
we're going to search over
then we're going to specify the metrics
that we're interested in
now i'm going to specify the area under
the
precision recall curve and the area
under the
uh roc curve now we're going to pipe to
that
this collect metrics function and then
bam
we have a whole lot of different results
here
for the various values of m tri that we
were searching over
now this is a lot of super helpful
information
i see a lot of times area under the uh
precision recall curve is less than 0.5
area under the roc a curve seems to be
hovering around
0.63 or 0.64 a lot of the time
this is too much output to sift through
and we want a robust way of actually
looking through this
so i'm going to come up with a
programmatic way of finding
uh what our optimal value of m tri could
be
so i look i reported uh area under the
uh precision recall curve here before
but
maybe i'm more interested in the area
under the roc
so let's filter down to a metric of
uh roc underscore auc
now we're going to find the row which
maximizes
uh the mean uh well rock
our area under the roc in this instance
so
let's programmatically pull uh what
value of m tri that is out
then we're going to pass that to the m
tri
argument to random forest so you see
what i did there
store to this m try uh object here the
best performing and try and then
just go through uh the training process
like we did before
okay fit that to uh the training set
then let's go ahead and generate our
predictions in a probability form
now notice here when i generate
predictions for the test set classes
take a look at this observation here for
instance it gives us
two columns one is the probability of
being in the bad class
one of them is the probability of being
in the good class take this first
observation here
the probability of being in the bad
class is 0.054
the probability of being in the good
class is 0.946
now if we return these probabilities in
just the class prediction form what it
would do
is say the probability of being in the
bad class
is 0.5 or higher like these observations
are
well those are the observations which
are going to get predicted to be in the
bad class
that threshold for being classified in
the bad class
is 0.5 well you can go in and just
manually
create your own uh predicted class
values
by playing with this output say for
instance you just want to
want to generate your own vector of
class predictions by
taking the bad class and then when it's
point
or the bad class probabilities here
excuse me
and then whenever it's let's say 0.333
or higher
oh let's just assign those observations
to the
uh predicted bad class so you can go
ahead and do that
kind of manually alt altering that
threshold for
what you're predicting to be in a given
class and in fact
that's one of my preferred methods of
correcting for class imbalance
you saw in the previous tutorial we
tried down sampling as an approach for
for dealing with class imbalance so
we're not going to walk through a full
example of
this kind of approach here but just know
that that's that's an option that you
have at your disposal that is oftentimes
quite powerful so the next thing that
we're going to do here is create a
visualization of an roc
curve and if you've gone through my
carrot tutorial series
the steps here are completely identical
to the steps there
so what we need here are two objects
one containing the predictions and one
containing the labels
by the way all this is coming from the
rocr package
unfortunately that's neither in the
carat framework or the tidy models
framework but
it's the best visualization package for
roc curves at this time that i'm
personally aware of
so for the predictions object the syntax
here is a little bit
strange because it's not super clear
well do we want the probabilities for
being
in the good class or the bad class so
it's not super clear
but so you'll have to trial and error it
a little bit
but typically i've found if you pass
the probability predictions for the
majority class to it
that that's the one that it wants so
again just trial and error this if you
run into problems
then obviously for the labels that's the
source of truth
that's the class variable from the test
set in our case here
so these two objects are going to get
passed to the prediction function
again this comes from the rocr package
so we're going to create this object
here called uh pred
okay well that's going to get passed to
this next function performance which uh
that creates an object based on the
metrics that we want
to actually visualize so
think about what an roc curve actually
is
an roc curve is going to visualize the
true positive rate
that is sensitivity against the false
positive rate
that is one minus specificity
so if you go into the help documentation
for the performance function you can
find
all the different metrics that you can
visualize but i'm going to pass
as arguments to the performance function
tpr
for true positive rate and fpr for false
positive rate
so we're going to create a plot of that
we're going to just specify to this
argument average equals
threshold and then colorize equals true
now you're probably going to know that
your roc curve
looks appropriate if uh the body of the
curve
is over the diagonal line going from 0
0 to 1 1
if it's above that diagonal imaginary
line here
that tells you the area under that curve
is greater than 0.5
meaning for this part right here that
means you probably got it right
so we've created our visualization here
this is a beautiful thing
to include uh in reports or or
applications which describe how well
uh your classifier is actually
performing on the testing set
so a great thing to have in your toolbox
here
now we've saved the best and most
exciting topic in this tidy models
tutorial series for last
and that's going to be stacking or
ensembling the predictions from various
models
so let me put it this way i want to take
a random forest classifier
a k nearest neighbors classifier and a
support vector machines classifier
and put all of those together into one
uh
for lack of a better term super
classifier
well tidy models is going to make that
super easy for us
okay so let's start with the random
forest model and i don't even need this
line of code here but i'm just including
it here so you
remember we defined a random forest
model earlier
but we need to define the specifications
for the k nearest neighbors
and for the support vector machines so
what i'm going to do here is we use this
nearest neighbor
like remember you can go up here and
search for
uh your parsnip model specifications
through a ui
if you prefer to do it that way but
basically we need
mode equals classification and then for
uh
for the neighbors argument that's a
hyper parameter to k
nearest neighbors i'm going to specify i
want to tune that later
the engine for this is going to come
from the kkn package which i loaded at
the beginning of
at the beginning of the script and we're
going to go through a similar process
for the svm model
specify the svm underscore rbf
function which under the cover specifies
that we want a radial kernel for support
vector machines
this is going to have two hyper
parameters cost and
rbf sigma which again we're going to to
both of those later
the engine is going to be the current
lab
library which again we loaded at the
beginning now for each of these models
we need to create
a workflow the random force workflow has
already been defined
so the workflow for k-nearest neighbors
and support vector machines
it's totally uh straightforward
we're going to specify the down recipe
which we created before for the random
forest
the same thing is going to work for k
nearest neighbors and support vector
machines
just pipe after the recipe the models
that we defined and
we are ready to go so all this code is
going to look remarkably similar to what
we just ran before
the only difference is for later we are
going to need this control stack
grid thing here so that's just another
argument that's going to go to the tune
grid function
but now here instead of manually
specifying the range of values that we
want to search for over the hyper
parameters
we're just going to specify just pick uh
just be smart about it
and just specify the number of different
values of hyperparameters we want to
search over
so if you know uh the tune length
of uh argument from carrot
it's just analogous to that we're just
specifying just
try seven different values for hyper
parameters for each of these
uh classifiers so i'm also not even
going to look over
uh the area under the precision recall
curve
all i want to do is find the uh
value of this of these hyper parameters
that maximize
area under the receiver operating
characteristic curve
okay go from there the syntax looks just
like it did before
all of this so far has largely just been
a set up to the real meat and potatoes
of the stax package
and that's what we're going to get into
here so
stacks much like themis as we saw
earlier for the down sampling and the up
sampling
this is another package outside of the
core tidy models ecosystem
that you are going to have to load
separately from tidy models
but let's get into the real beauty from
this package
so to start stacking the predictions
from various classifiers
we have to start by defining a data
stack object
so the this this type of code is
analogous to like
initializing a ggplot object using the
ggplot function
we're going to start by initializing
this with the stacks function
and then pipe to it uh
various candidates so the candidates are
all these definitions for
classifiers that we defined up above
so all these re-samples that we defined
for the random forest the k
ears neighbors and the support vector
machines where you have
various different configurations for
hyper parameters
all of those are candidates and they're
going to get piped to this data stack
object up top here
makes sense and you can just call the
credit stack object which
i just defined up here and it'll just
give you some basic information
it's just a data stack with three model
definitions
and 21 candidate members seven model
configurations for random forest for k
nearest neighbors for support vector
machines etc etc
the next step is we're actually going to
blend the predictions from these various
candidates
we're going to do this using an aptly
named blend predictions function
now how this works is it evaluates your
data stack by fitting a regularized
model on the assessment predictions from
each candidate member
and to do this it uses a lasso model
so lasso being a common regularization
technique
it's going to assign each of these
candidates
a beta parameter or a weight and now
if the weight is greater than zero then
that candidate gets kept
if the weight is equal to zero then that
candidate gets dropped
so the argument that you do need to
specify here is the penalty factor
and if we look at the documentation here
it can range all the way from uh
10 to the negative six all the way all
the way up to
uh 10 to the negative one so i'm just
gonna
kind of arbitrarily select a penalty
equal to .001
and then we create this new uh credit
model stack object and i find that
uh the weights on uh here's a random
forest candidate here's a rent here's
another random forest candidate and
here's a support vector machines
candidates
it turns out those were the only three
candidates which returned a weight
greater than zero uh there's more uh
information if you look at this uh part
of the output from the r
console but the real meat and potatoes
of the output here
is this table that gets returned and
then similarly if you want to use the
auto plot function you can go ahead and
create a visualization of these
uh these stacking coefficients there is
one final step that we need to do
here in order to fit the model stack
members with non-zero stacking
coefficients
and so all we have to do to the stack
that we've created in this
pipeline we've been working through thus
far all we need to do is pipe to that
the fit
members function so just do that
and now we are ready to use this
supermodel
as i've been defining it basically a
model that combines the predictions from
these various different
candidate models that we've been working
with we are ready to evaluate the
performance of that thing
on the testing set the way we have any
other classifier we've been working with
in this tutorial series
so the syntax for that looks exactly the
same as everything we've been working
with so far
when we evaluate this thing on the
testing set we see
uh the accuracy is actually worse than
the very first model that we fit at the
beginning of this tutorial
and we're back at the same problem where
we have fairly imbalanced
sensitivity and specificity so
this i think really speaks to a broader
just philosophical concept that
the more complicated model is not always
a better one
now i've been generally working with a
fairly simple approach here
and maybe i could go ahead and make this
thing even more complicated by just
adding more and more candidates
uh specifying maybe uh maybe a greater
length possible values of hyper
parameters that i wanted to tune over
but at the end of the day sometimes
regardless of what your
intended outcome is a simpler and more
parsimonious model
may be better so i'm gonna leave you
there
hopefully you've enjoyed this series on
tidy models
hopefully you've gotten something out of
it and you know how to use these
packages to tackle the next machine
learning problem that you work on
so if you enjoyed this video please
consider sharing it
smash the like button also leave me a
comment down below and let me know do
you like carrot more
do you like tidy models more uh which
one's easier
just just start a discussion down in the
comments down below
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data